is the shirt sheer is it see-through
what is happening it is sheer
yeah we've got a little we've got a
little skin going on in there yeah
how does that how does it feel to be at
your first official red carpet
it feels great you know like this show
has been such a labor of love and it's
one of those things where we're so
excited for the world
not just to accept it to be in a place
like this to where
everybody is here and we're kind of
around people that we've admired
yeah so it's kind of a pinch me moment
actually it's really exciting
it feels a little surreal yes this is
all of our like our first
red official yeah i was going to say
that's what they all said too i do have
to know did you and chase plan out
no the red this was an enough no not at
all not at all we like
we have when we found out we were both
wearing basically the same color we were
like
wait further places that you guys are
meant to be
i mean it's such a i mean for the first
red carpet it's such a power color
it's such a it's such it's so fun yeah
and so i mean i don't i don't blame him
what about all this bling tell me about
this bling on you we are in versace head
to toe tonight
this one's for donatella i talked to
maddie and i
had to ask her did you guys color
coordinate you're big coming out
as crazy as it is like you know we
didn't like i walked upstairs because i
was getting done and i walked up and i
was like oh my gosh
we kept it a secret for a while i was
like i don't want to tell you what i'm
wearing and she was like i don't want to
tell you what i'm wearing so yeah
it's kind of cool to finally come here
and be like oh we kind of walked
downstairs got in the car and we're like
this is kind of a moment red carpet red
suits so
we know that season two is finally
coming back this summer i know
where are john b and sarah at in season
two
all i can say is that we're in the
bahamas
all of the whole season no just the
beginning
just the beginning how has the
relationship affected the writers room
i don't think honestly you know
our writers pull from what we what we
give
and so i think it's honestly just i
think it's just made it more real
yeah more visceral which can only help
and um and we
we pull from our own chemistry as a
group all the time
in the show in our scenes so i feel like
it can only make it better yeah
you know being together in real life how
did that affect the writers room in john
b and sarah's
relationship on the show we've had a lot
of conversation about how we can
separate the two so we have you know
maddie and chase and we have john p and
sarah so
we've had a lot of time with you know
being in quarantine and being locked
down and in isolation to really talk
about the nuances between john b and
sarah
and then what we have personally and how
we can bring that to the screen so
i'm excited for the fans to see it i'm
excited for them to you know sort of
pick it apart as they do and find the
little moments that we've created but
um you know it's two different
relationships in two different worlds so
it's fun to bring both together
and to find little moments but keep them
separate i love that
she did tell me quote love is tight
i saw that headline and i was like all
right that's good
good choice of words how does season two
live up to season one or compare to
season one i will say it is incredibly
high octane
it's um it's another fun journey it's
more treasure hunts it's more excitement
um but most importantly it's really
about the friendship so yeah i'm just
super thankful to be a part of a show
that gives an authentic take on
friendship and that gives you
a true glimpse into what it's like to go
to the end of the world for your friends
so
i think people are gonna love it what
does it mean to you
um it's just been such a fun adventure i
mean like this is a very
stressful experience to have a show come
out right
and then have the world experience it
and then on top of that have people
accept the show
and you know to be accepted on on such a
level that the show was accepted on is
is such a beautiful thing but it adds a
level of pressure to it right
yep so we're just you know sort of
keeping our fingers crossed that people
you know continue to follow the show and
have a good time and we've had a blast
shooting it i mean this season was
incredibly exciting to film so
you know regardless of the pandemic we
have such a great family of crew and
cast and so
i'm just i'm so excited for people to
see it we're excited one word to
describe the new season
chaos is there anyone tonight that
you're dying to meet or that you're very
excited to meet scarlett johansson is
getting
the generation award i know i know are
you fangirling over a little bit
a little bit there's a lot of people i'm
fangirling and i'm like i don't know
um i heard snoop though was gonna be
here he i think he's djing tonight
yep yep okay make sure she's alive
i need to check on maddie might need
some ice cubes
is there anyone you're excited to meet
tonight i mean scarlett johansson's
getting the generation award
i mean i've had a long time crush on
scarjo so you know
to see her accept an award like that and
you know just to be honored for her work
i mean it's
it's such an incredible moment so
congrats to her
you